>> Greg: PSYCHOLOGIST HAVE
CONFIRMED THAT YES THE PANDEMIC
IN THE ECONOMY THE WAR IN
UKRAINE COME TO MAKE RIB NOT
BEING AVAILABLE ALL YEAR ROUND
HAS DEFINITELY MESSED WITH OUR
HEADS.
THE AMERICAN PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION.
[LAUGHS]
THEY PUBLISH A WIDE-RANGING
ANNUAL STRESS IN AMERICA SURVEY
WHICH IS A REAL PAIN IN THE TO
FILL OUT BY THE WAY.
BUT HE FOUND OUT THAT 87% OF
AMERICANS FEEL LIKE THAT THERE
BEEN A CONSTANT STREAM OF CAN'T
CRISES, THANKS JOE BIDEN, OR
OBAMA, OR OBAMA-BIDEN, MICHELLE.
[LAUGHS]
AND MORE THAN 75% FEEL
OVERWHELMED BY IT.
THE REMAINING 27%.
EVERYONE HE PASSED BY ON THE
STREET WILL BE ON THE VERGE OF A
MILE DOWN, PUNCHING IN THE FACE
AT ANY MOMENT, ESPECIALLY FOR
INITIALS ARE DANA PERINO.
AND IT'S TRUE.
PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR MINDS.
AND BY PEOPLE YOU MEAN IDIOTS
LIKE "NEW YORK TIMES" COLLEGES
WHO PREDICT THAT VIOLENCE
TOWARDS MASS SQUARES AFTER THE
MASS MANDATE WAS DROPPED.
IF ONLY THERE WAS SOMEONE A
PULSE OUT OF THIS, WHICH WE DO
ABOUT THIS MR. PRESIDENT?
>> HEY, HEY COME ON MAN LOOK.
I UNDERSTAND PEOPLE ARE STRESSED
OUT I UNDERSTAND IT.
BUT I TOLD YOU WHAT IT WAS
ABOUT.
THIS TWO REASONS FOR IT ALREADY.
VLADIMIR COVID, PUTIN 19.
BOTH OF THOSE GUYS LOOK.
OLD JOE I KNOW HOW TO DO THIS
THING RIGHT, I KNOW WHAT IT
FEELS LIKE WE NEED TO PUT FOOD
IN YOUR GAS TANK OKAY.
YOU LISTEN TO PEOPLE YOU DO WHAT
YOU'RE TOLD.
IF YOU WOULD DO WHAT THEY TOLD
HIM AND ONE TO TAKE OFF HER
SHOES WE GOING TO THE BUS
STATIONS.
ON THE AIRPORT.
ON THE...
THING THERE.
>> Greg: THE PRESIDENT MAKES A
GOOD POINT THERE TYRUS.
A LOT OF STRESS IS DRIVEN BY
PEOPLE MEDDLING IN OTHER
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
WE STEP THE COMMUNITY ANNOUNCING
A REVERSE COMMUNITY.
A SET OF PEOPLE HELPING YOU LIKE
YOUR NEIGHBORS WE CAN BORROW
LAWN TOOLS.
ELSE LIKE OTHER PEOPLE YOU DON'T
KNOW TELL YOU HOW TO LEAD YOUR
LIFE.
>> Tyrus: THERE ARE REAL
PROBLEMS IN THIS FIRST WORLD
PROBLEMS.
FIRST WORLD PROBLEMS SEEM TO BE
WORTH ANYTHING.
OH, I'M WORRIED ABOUT HOW MANY
PIECES OF PAPER GO IN HERE GREG.
HOW MANY TREES ARE YOU MURDERING
YOU MURDEROUS PASTORATE.
AND I CAN'T SLEEP AT NIGHT THING
ABOUT THAT, THAT'S ON A REAL
PROBLEM IT SOUNDS GOOD AND IS
VIRTUE SIGNALING.
HOW MIGHTY MY BILLS THIS MONTH.
REAL PROBLEMS IS MY KID RAN AWAY
FROM SCHOOL, I'M DEALING WITH
FAMILY DRUG ADDICTION, THOSE ARE
REAL PROBLEMS IN AMERICAN DEAL
WITH AND STILL FIND WAYS TO MAKE
THEIR LIVES WORK AND GO.
THE NOT DOING THE SURVEY, IT'S
THE ONES IN THE SAFE SPACES WERE
LIKE SO UPSET BECAUSE SOMEONE
SAID THE F WORD ON TV AND THEY
NEED TO GO DOWN.
OR I KNOW YOU SAID SOMETHING IN
1981 AND WE HAVE DEFINED IT.
THAT'S WHAT'S TAKING THE PLACE
WHAT PROBLEMS ARE.
THESE FAKE PROBLEMS BECAUSE OF
VIRTUAL SIGNALING IS THE NEW
THING TO DO TO BE ON TV BECAUSE
YOU GET A LOT OF ATTENTION
FORWARD.
YOU'VE SEVERE PTSD.
SEVERE CRAIG.
SEVERE.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW KAT WHAT
I'VE NOTICED IS THAT I DO
BELIEVE THAT THE MASK IS A NEW
IDENTITY.
BECAUSE IF THEY SAY THAT YOU
COULD BE VICTIMIZED THAT THE
VICTIM CLASS.
WE MIGHT HAVE MASK HATE CRIMES.
YOU KNOW?
YES.
>> Kat: WE PROBABLY WILL.
>> Greg: UNMASKED MEGA
SUPPORTERS PUTTING A NOOSE
AROUND YOUR NECK FOR WEARING A
MASK.
>> Kat: I DON'T KNOW DOES HE
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
TRUE OR NOT AND I DON'T KNOW
WHICH ONE IS WORSE?
I REALLY DON'T THINK THAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN.
I STILL WANT TO SEE PEOPLE STILL
IN NEW YORK THIS PEOPLE OUTSIDE
WHO WEAR MASKS I GENERALLY,
MAYBE THEY HAVE SOME KIND OF
MEDICAL CONDITION I DON'T THINK
THAT YOU'RE STUPID BUT I'M NOT
GONNA HIT YOU.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE TO BE BEATING
PEOPLE UP IF THEY WANT TO WEAR
MASKS.
I JUST DON'T WANT SOMEONE TO
FORCE ME TO WEAR A MASK.
AND IT'S BEEN SO FUN FOR THEM
FOR SO MANY YEARS TO HAVE ALL
THESE OPTIONS OF OU WENT OUT AND
THAT MAKES YOU A BAD PERSON.
I WEAR THIS MASS SOME A BETTER
PERSON.
USUALLY AT THE PUT IN MORE
EFFORT TO HAVE PEOPLE THINK
YOU'RE A GOOD PERSON BUT HERE I
THINK THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
MORNING MORE THAN THE MASKS.
>> Greg: IS THE MASK THE NEW
WESTERN BURQA?
I'M PRETTY IMPRESSED.
>> WHEN YOU DECIDE THAT YOUR
PERSONAL LIBERTY AND OTHER
PEOPLE'S PERSONAL LIBERTIES ARE
IMPORTANT, YOUR LIFE GETS SO
MUCH BETTER THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO WORRY ABOUT WHAT OTHER PEOPLE
ARE DOING.
YOU WANT TO WORRY ABOUT HOW THE
RACE AND THE KIDS, HOW TO
WEARING A MASK OR NOT.
IF SO MUCH MORE FREE TIME TO
ENJOY YOUR LIFE.
BUT IT IS TRUE I FEEL LIKE THERE
HAS BEEN TWO YEARS OF STRESS AND
THINGS BEEN A DIFFICULT CENTURY
TO BE HONEST.
A LOT OF THINGS GOING ON.
THAT'S PROBABLY ALL DECIDE TO DO
THE HEALTHY THING TO TAKE ALL
THOSE FEELINGS AND BOW THEM UP
STICK THEM IN A VERY SECRET
PLACE.
>> Rob: AND PRETEND NONE OF IT
EVER HAPPENED.
>> Greg: THE SOLUTION IS
DRUGS.
LEGAL MUSHROOMS WILL PROBABLY
SOLVE ALL OF THIS.
YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING WE
TALK ABOUT THE STRESS THE STUDY
COMES OUT YOU KNOW WHAT'S
MISSING FROM ALL THE STRESS?
DONALD TRUMP.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE PERSON
CAUSING ALL THE STRESS.
AND HE'S GONE.
HE'S NOT AROUND.
HE'S NOT TWEETING AND YET WE
HAVE ALL THE STRESS.
I BLAME IT ON THE LIBERALS.
THEY COULD'VE BEEN THE TITLE MY
NEW BROOK STOMACH BOOK.
[LAUGHS]
>> THEY GOT ADDICTED TO THE
STRESS.
WHAT IF ALL THE STRESSES OF ALL
THE BUSYBODIES THAT WILL THE
LANDS LAST YEAR.
SUPER STRESSED OUT THAT THEY
CAN'T MAKE YOU WEAR THE MASK ON
THE AIRPLANE THAT YOU'RE
STANDING TOO CLOSE TO THEM AND
THEY CAN CONTROL YOU ANYMORE.
THOSE POOR THINGS.
I REALLY DO THINK THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING WRONG WITH IT.
BUT I'VE COME BUT I FIND IT
ENTERTAINING.
RYAN, ONE OF THE STREET LIKE A
MASK OR IMAGINE WHAT THEY
BELIEVE.
>> Greg: BUT IT IS.
THIS IN THE LEG WORK CREATING
IDENTITY FOR THEM.
THEY'RE EMBRACING IDENTITY, IT
IS CAN BE PART OF THE LIBERAL
COMPONENT THAT MAKES UP FOR THE
MOSAIC OF LIBERAL LIFE WITH YOUR
PRO-CHOICE, GUN CONTROL, MASK.
>> Kat: THEY COULD JUST WEAR
THE MASK LIKE SO MANY OTHER
PEOPLE WEARING AND ALL THE
PICTURES ARE BACK ON TWITTER.
I'M STILL WEARING MY MASK ON THE
PLANE.
WAIT GO AHEAD.
>> THIS IS A GREAT BENEFIT FOR
US, WEAR THE MASK.
EASIEST POSSIBLE SOLUTION.
DON'T PASS ANY LAWS.
>> I NO CAPS ON HAD A HEAD HER
MASK ON.
JUST WEAR A SHIRT AND SHOES
PLEASE.
AND PANTS.
I'M